En otros videos hemos hablado de la noción de
polinomio. Un polinomio es una suma o resta de
términos algebraicos, como cada término algebraico
tiene coeficientes y variables, entonces podemos
decir que las partes de un polinomio son todos
sus términos, cada uno con sus coeficientes
y sus variables. Ahora bien, cuando tenemos un
polinomio igualado a otra expresión matemática,
decimos que tenemos una ecuación, ¿cierto? Para
resolver algunas ecuaciones, lo más sencillo es
igualarlas a 0. También hemos mencionado que si
tenemos un polinomio p(x), podemos encontrar sus
raíces al igualar el polinomio a 0, y encontrar
los valores de x que satisfagan la ecuación,
es decir, r es una raíz del polinomio p(x) si p(r)
es igual a 0. Sin embargo, encontrar las raíces de
un polinomio no siempre es tan sencillo. En este
video hablaremos de las fórmulas de Vieta y cómo
se relacionan con los coeficientes del polinomio
para encontrar sus raíces. Francisco Vieta fue un
matemático francés que nació en 1540, en un inicio
estudió derecho y fue miembro del parlamento de
París. Imagina que tienes un polinomio de
la forma x² + bx + c. Vieta concluyó que,
la suma de sus raíces, r1 + r2, debe de ser
igual a -b y el producto de las raíces, r1 • r2,
debe de ser igual a c. Llegó a esta conclusión
a partir de que r1 y r2 son raíces de p(x);
entonces es posible expresar x² + bx + c como (x
- r1) (x - r2), y si hacemos este producto notable
tenemos que x² + bx + c es igual a x² - r1 • x -
r2 • x + r1 • r2. Si factorizamos a x tenemos que:
x² - r1 + r2 • x + r1 • r2; y si queremos que
estas dos expresiones sean iguales, entonces
b debe de ser igual a: - r1 + r2, o -b es igual a
r1 + r2, y, por otra parte, c debe de ser igual a
r1 • r2. Y a estas se les conoce como las fórmulas
de Vieta para una ecuación de segundo grado. Por
ejemplo, si pensamos en el polinomio p(x) = x²
- πx + √3, no es fácil obtener estas raíces,
pero sí podemos saber cómo se relacionan entre
ellas. Lo que nos dicen las fórmulas de Vieta
es que la suma de las raíces siempre es igual
a -b, que es el negativo del coeficiente del
término de primer grado. Entonces sabemos que, en
este caso, r1 + r2 debe de ser igual a π. También
podemos saber la relación entre el producto de
las raíces: sabemos que r1 • r2 = c, que en este
caso es √3. Bien, hagamos un ejemplo. Encuentra
las raíces de x² + x - 6 = 0. Pausa el video,
usa las fórmulas de Vieta e intenta encontrar
las raíces antes de que lo hagamos juntos.
Bueno, lo que nos dicen las fórmulas de Vieta
es que r1 + r2 debe de ser igual a -b, y en este
caso, b = 1, entonces tendremos que r1 + r2 = -1,
y por otra parte r1 • r2 debe de ser igual a c,
que aquí es -6; entonces tenemos que buscar dos
números cuya suma sea -1 y su producto sea -6.
Bueno, lo primero que podemos notar es que,
como el resultado del producto es negativo,
una de las raíces debe de ser positiva y
la otra negativa, porque la única forma de
obtener un número negativo del producto de dos
números es que éstos sean de signos distintos,
es decir, + • - = - o - • + = -. Y si pensamos
en los múltiplos de 6 tenemos 3 y 2 y 6 y 1,
entonces si la primera raíz fuera -3 y la segunda
fuera 2, la suma nos daría -1 y el producto sería
-6. Así que ya está, usando las fórmulas de Vieta
hemos encontrado las raíces. Seguramente esto
te parece familiar, ya que en otros videos hemos
visto cómo resolver cuadráticas por factorización,
y en Khan Academy tenemos muchos ejercicios sobre
el tema. Una de las ventajas de las fórmulas de
Vieta es que muchos de los sistemas de ecuaciones
se pueden resolver por inspección. Bien, pensemos
en el siguiente ejemplo. Encuentra el valor de b
y c si sabemos que las raíces son 3 y -5. Bien,
pausa el video e intenta encontrar
el valor para b y c en x² + bx + c.
Ok, vamos a trabajarlo juntos. Sabemos que las
raíces son 3 y -5, entonces r1 = 3 y r2 = -5; por
otra parte, usando las fórmulas de Vieta, sabemos
que r1 + r2 = -b y que r1 • r2 = c. Entonces, si
sustituimos tenemos que: 3 + -5, esto debe de ser
igual a -b, y 3 • -5, esto debe de ser igual a c;
entonces nos queda que -b de ser igual a -2 o
b debe de ser igual a 2 si multiplicamos ambos
lados por -1, y que c es igual a -15. Entonces el
polinomio cuyas raíces son 3 y -5 es el polinomio
x² + bx + c, pero en lugar de b pondremos 2 y
en lugar de c pondremos -15: x² + 2x -15. Bien,
intentemos un último ejercicio. Ahora queremos
encontrar las raíces de 2x² + 7x - 4. Bien,
antes de que pauses el video, quiero que
observes que, en esta ocasión, el coeficiente
del término cuadrático no es 1, entonces, ¿cómo
podemos utilizar la fórmula de Vieta? Bueno,
lo que proponía Vieta era primero dividir el
polinomio entre el coeficiente del término mayor,
para que éste sea 1 y así poder obtener las raíces
de la misma manera que en los otros dos ejemplos
anteriores. Es decir, si dividimos todo entre 2
tenemos que nuestro polinomio es: 2x² / 2 es lo
mismo que x², 7x / 2, bueno, esto es lo mismo que
7/2x, y -4 / 2 es lo mismo que -2. Entonces nos
queda que x² + 7/2x - 2 debe de ser igual a 0.
Ahora bien, buscamos dos números r1 y r2, tales
que su suma sea -7/2 y su producto r1 • r2 sea
igual a -2. Pausa el video e intenta encontrarlos.
Bien, podemos darnos cuenta de que una de las
raíces será positiva y la otra negativa, porque
el producto es negativo; también podemos pensar
que al menos una de las raíces es racional, porque
la suma es racional, así que intentemos primero
con algún número que tenga como denominador 2.
Veamos lo que pasaría si una de las raíces fuera
1/2, bueno, y entonces la otra raíz tendría que
ser -4 ya que 1/2 • -4 es lo mismo que -2,
pero 1/2 - 4 = -7/2 medios, entonces ya está,
lo logramos: r1 = 1/2 y r2 = -4. Y ya está,
hemos acabado. Es hora de que nos preguntemos
qué pasará con polinomios con grado mayor. Bueno,
en el siguiente video trabajaremos las fórmulas
de Vieta para algunas ecuaciones cúbicas,
así que nos vemos en el siguiente video.